مدينه ثانيه تصدرتا الانباء والانباء
المضاده والمتناقضه بين الروس
والاوكرانيين في مكيفا اعتراف روسي نادر
موسكو اقرت بمقتل 89
عسكريا في المدينه الصناعيه التي تبعد 15
كلم
باعداد موسكو قالت انها اعلى بعشره اضعاف
روسيا كان لابد ان ترد فهمتها مستت وهنا
جاء الهجوم على كروماتوس شمال دنياك قالت
روسيا ان قوتها قتلت اكثر من 600 جنديا
اوكرانيه هناك والهجوم تنفي ثياب وقوعه
اصلا وكثيرا مالجا الطرفان الى التضليل
منذ اندلاع الحرب قالت هجمات اوكرانيا
هيبه روسيا في هجمه يا طراد مصباح هذا
اكبر مثال السفينه اغرقت ان احترقت
في كل الاحوال ضرب العمود الفقري البحريه
الروسيه وعلى بعد 700 و30 كم الجنوب
الشرقيه موسكو طالت المسيرات الاوكرانيه
احد اهم القواعد الاستراتيجيه الروسيه
وهنا نتحدث عن قاعده انجلز هذه القاعده
التي استهدفت اكثر من مره هي قاعده
الثالوث النووي لروسيا القاذفات
الاستراتيجيات الثقيله تتمركز هنا اكتوبر
لم يكن سهلا على الروس ولاسيما على الرئيس
بوتن وهو يشاهد الجسر القرم او جسر
الاستراتيجيه يشتعل بعمليه تفجير مركبه
مفخخه لان الهزيمه ليست خيارا بالنسبه له
اختار بوتا حلا اخر جعل الوقت يلعب ضد
اوكرانيا القوات الروسيه تؤكد السيطره على
سوليدار في محور محمود يعني السيطره على
البوابه الجنوبيه في عنقي دنيا يس وذلك
رغم نفي اوكرانيا مجددا لكنها تعترف هذه
المره الوضع صعب
في اوكرانيا تتركز المعركه في ثلاثه محاور
رئيسيه ضخمه التي تؤكد اوكرانيا
وهو ما اجبر الروس على تغيير خططهم
العسكريه والاكتفاء بحارها وهنا تاتي
اهميه سوليدار حيث ركزت قواتنار جهودها
عليها لقطع الامداد واحكام حصار باخمن اقر
بصعوبه الاوضاع هناك خاصه طرق الامداد
الاستراتيجيه التي باتت في مرمى نيرانوس
تمثل اهميه استراتيجيه للدفاع عن بعض كما
هو الحال للمدن الكبرى المتبقيه تحت سيطره
الاوكرانيين داخل الحدود الاداريه
مهام جديده صعبه امام القوات الروسيه الان
وهي السيطره على مدينتي
وكرامترز خط الدفاع الرئيسي للقوات
الاوكرانيه تحقق القوات الروسيه اختراقات
كبيره في خط الدفاع في دمباز ونجاحات
حاسمه في ضخمه وسيلر وهي نقاط استراتيجيه
مهمه تحاول القياده الاوكرانيه الاحتفاظ
بها باي ثمن كان تعتبر موسكو ان هزيم
تركيا
لن تكون عسكريه فقط وانما سياسيه ونفسيه
ايضا